the ftc is suing facebook um attempting
to break them
up um and uh under the leadership of
who's someone who seems to be a true
badass um or at least aligned with a lot
of i think lena kahn who's the um
have you read about this one she's the
new ftc chair she's 32 she's 32.
like come on like you're embarrassing
that's amazing she's a badass
yeah she wrote a paper in 2017 called
amazon's
anti-trust paradox paper went viral in
these influential circles
let's call it like it went law school
viral i guess
um and she argued that the dominance of
the text titans like amazon showed that
the u.s anti-trust
laws are broken um because they're
focused
on consumer pricing instead of basically
like competition
um and so the argument is like well
what do we care it's not a monopoly if
consumers are paying less money and
their argument is that well that's a
dated
view of monopoly so basically the ftc
has been filing a bunch of anti-trust
lawsuits against a number of big tech
companies
the news this week is that a judge
basically
didn't so didn't last the ftc out of the
courtroom but was like dismissed the
case before it even
got its day in court and that was
shocking like that
that was not what people were expecting
and and the judge gave
the ftc basically 30 days if i'm not
going to save it or
like to improve their case and come back
with an improved case before
it's able to move forward i the media
has not
said this so i'm going to say it this
was lena's first
shot like some of the things the judge
is saying
judge james bosberg that's kind of a
cool name
or whisper anyway he said a couple
things one
you concluded that facebook you being
the fcc concluded that facebook has a
market share of 60
but back that up with no data no obvious
reasoning so
that feels like a rookie i don't know
enough about loss i don't know but that
feels like a
no no look look up from me right now
when when was lena
appointed to the ftc chair i believe it
was in the last like month like yeah
that exists in this case at present
predate okay so not me
but still like she's gotta know it's
this is i think
wrong stuff so and so the thing is now
is like her first real big move honestly
as the ftc chair is going to be spending
the next 30 days
fixing this working to strengthen this
case like she's now inherited this
problem and
i think the real measure of her and it's
a tall order so i don't necessarily
think we should write her off even if
she doesn't do if she doesn't if it
doesn't work but
the real measure of her is going to be
over the next 30 days
when they come back to the judge the big
hurdle they're fighting though is like
that
facebook bought instagram in 2012 and
whatsapp in 2014
and those were both reviewed by um
anti-dress court at the time and they
found no problem
and then so the quest the judge is like
why why did you wait so long if you
really
now 10 years later you're bringing an
issue and that's not his fault
um that is a number of reasons um so i'm
curious your thoughts on
angie talks with us a lot he thinks um
you know they're not a traditional
monopoly but they are
uh they're selling our data we get the
product fee and they sell our data and a
lot of people don't know that they don't
know the depths of it there's so many
different sides of this um but thoughts
on
your thoughts on this in general carl
and then where do you think this goes
yeah where do we think we land
well the angle that i
always that i feel like has been missing
when i've the little bit that i've kind
of read and dug into this has always
been the okay
what does breaking these companies up
mean for consumers
right like for you and me why do i care
about this what does it mean for me
and like what are the pros of doing this
and and you talked about david
data privacy i think i don't understand
how
separating instagram and whatsapp from
facebook does anything for my data
privacy it doesn't so
that's andrew's point yeah so so i i
think that's
so i'm like okay what good he's always
said that what good does it do if you
make another
google maps and a bunch of like five
smaller googles doesn't make
google doesn't like increase competition
per se maybe a little
well but but is that the argument is
that
more competition will mean more people
trying to woo consumers and one of the
ways they may try to woo
us is by having better data privacy
settings like maybe that's the
roundabout argument but frankly most
people don't actually give that much of
a [ __ ] about
data privacy like they're like i got
nothing to hide fine take my data like
so i don't see that playing out i think
the other the other argument i guess
as i've kind of dug into this is like
all right it increases competition for
small businesses for smaller players
that's great i i don't understand how
breaking up again instagram and facebook
does that just set the precedent that
facebook couldn't buy up its competition
in the future like
i don't really understand how breaking
those up necessarily protects smaller
businesses um so this is the piece that
i've always been confused on is
great in theory i guess i'm for breaking
up big tech but i don't actually really
understand how it helps me
or well the thing is that all the data
is owned by facebook right or these
three or four companies and the problem
is if you want to
market in the 21st century you have to
use facebook and that's like the
that's what you're trying to avoid right
that's what you tried no you have to use
facebook
king um and so we had a we had a
conversation on
e-commerce and we talked about if you're
like it's it's amazing for these young
companies to come on like you can hyper
target and
not have to carry inventory because you
know exactly who's buying in real time
but at the same time you have to use
facebook and is that good or bad for
okay but that's because all of the users
are there
no of course and that's where consumers
are and that's not changing if you
separate instagram and facebook
like none of this is i guess my point is
that like i don't understand breaking up
is not breaking up sounds good
it's not going to solve at all sure and
and you know i'm intrigued by this idea
which i think
you got into or lena talks about this
and and other people in the wake of this
court decision have been saying this
we really need to update our anti-trust
laws
to better reflect and
encapsulate sort of the internet age and
maybe that would be what we need to
solve these things that i'm talking
about but
otherwise i sort of feel like this feels
like an you know an elite
legal battle and i don't really care in
the sense that like i don't
really know what's in it for me if my
data is still just going to be sold
ad nauseam and facebook's still going to
have 10 billion users and the other
you know it's fun for me carl's like the
the con let's just take like the
conservative argument here
where it's like this is bipartisan it's
a lot of people but there is a certain
element was like hey
i'm conservative i'm pro-business and
like if you're a country on a global
scale you want your cash cows to kick
butt
and then you tax them and you tax your
billionaires
the people make billions off it um and
that's good for
government programs like you want cash
cows to fund your government
that all like i don't necessarily agree
with that argument but i i see the logic
until until you start to see what just
happened in propublica did a bombshell
report that said
like we've known that the facebook's
amazons don't pay any taxes so the
company itself is not paying [ __ ] tax
and the billionaires aren't paying
attention so that was a joke
nothing we're just letting our rich guys
run around that's ridiculous though i
will say here here's the
there's like this like secret republican
in me and i'm a big fan of like
you know let's tax these people tufts
vermont liberals secret republican tell
me more about her
carly well just more that like you know
and and jack dorsey is not like broadly
representative but like
he donated a third of his wealth like a
billion dollars this year towards like
covid prevention or covered research or
whatever the heck uh
women's education and ubi and i was like
women's education and ubi are basically
the two things that i think are going to
like
save the world women's education i think
that included like contraception like
there's so much research on how
contraception
is a game changer no country has lifted
itself out of
uh poverty in the last 50 years without
expanding access to contraception to
women
so so somebody like jack dorsey for me
it was like that billion dollars was
better off in his hands than in
the government's hands where it gets
siphoned off to like 10 trillion
different
you know little at least yeah
yeah of course and that's that's just
anecdotal and in general billionaires
don't give nearly enough away someone
who's worked a lot of philanthropists
uh that's true you were that was your
game
what the hell they're doing not that the
government does either but you know like
it's
like i don't know
at least theoretically checks and
bounces theoretically i
um i will say the last thing on this
unless you have other
super hot takes that you want to share i
i do get a kick out of a bipartisan
element of this
because it's this fun thing where you
have democrats just in general
are in favor of antitrust and government
regulation and conservatives just
hate big tech they just like hate jack
dorsey and they like
they're like we're being censored yeah
and so like
we have this funny like you know come
together for very different reasons
everybody kind of agrees on like yeah
you're kind of too big like there's a
problem here
i know and maybe it speaks to the
weakness of the government's case that
of course
hasn't been able to happen of course um
so this will be
you know like zuckerberg has done things
that objectively
whether you're really loose you want to
evolve your definition of anti-trust
laws or stick with the conservative ones
things where he has been quoted in the
email i think it was
two thousand look this right it was uh
i don't know i remember when he actually
i don't know the date sorry but he said
in an email it's better to buy than
compete
um in 2013 there was a social media
company called circle that was growing
um and they were competing a competing
social network
and when they couldn't buy it they just
cut off access to its data and systems
because that's how they were getting a
number
of uh of new users and such and so they
stopped we went from gaining 600 000 new
users a day
to zero um and that's like what facebook
yeah that's a problem
and that to me is a question of i i
guess this anti-trust regulation like
breaking up instagram and facebook
prevents that i'm just not clear enough
i suppose on whether or not
retroactively making changes to the
structure of facebook
prevents future actions by facebook um
to to suppress competition presumably
yes in which case great and i'm in favor
i'm not an expert maybe she's an
anti-trust law i'm curious of what
um i'd be fascinated to learn what was
happening during
like the rockefeller age where you had
um oh yeah
you know like what and like it was more
the wild west can i give a fun
rockefeller story
go for it okay this is from ap us
history i learned this
um so john rockefeller at like the
height of his
you know fortune success like richest
dude in the world
was taking a tour of one of his like oil
factories and they were putting the oil
in the barrels
and he asked them how many drops of glue
they used to seal the barrels of oil
and they told him and he was like all
right like try it with like with one
fewer and one fewer and basically was
like
to to save costs was like how few drops
of glue can we use to successfully seal
these these barrels of oil and it was
just like 16 year old me was like that's
what it takes to be successful like that
level of just detail and like
god how will i ever like compete with
something that that like you have all
the money in the world and you're still
like
how many drops of glue i want to save
that not even half a cent
you know meanwhile you probably got some
like poor like factory oil rig worker
who's got like rich ass john rockefeller
breathing down his neck being like this
[ __ ]
first you said five drops now it's four
[Music]
you